MALE SPEAKER: Hello,
everyone and welcome
to this afternoon's webinar.
My name's Greg Wilson.
I work for RStudio on
the education team.
And we've put this one
together to help everybody
who was finding themselves
moving their teaching online
at short notice.
I'd like to thank Robert
and Curtis for setting up
all of the mechanics for this.
And there is a question
tab in GoToWebinar,
please throw questions
into it at any time
during the presentation
we'll field some of them
during the call and we'll
gather up the rest at the end.
All right.
Let's get rolling because it's
a big world and a short day.
So you all had
plans, you all had
some idea of how you
were going to teach
a course this semester, how
you were going to deliver
that training workshop,
and now all of a sudden,
you find yourself in an
off road vehicle at night.
We've all of us been
thrown off our plans
in the last couple of weeks.
And quite reasonably,
a lot of us
were afraid that things are
going to crash out that.
We're here to help.
What we're going to do
in the next 45 minutes
is give you a few
tips that we hope
will help you move your teaching
online without crashing.
It's not the best you
could possibly do,
it's what you can do in a
hurry with the tools you've got
and the time you have.
Because like your
learners, you're
probably now wrestling
with a whole bunch
of issues around looking
after kids or elderly parents
travel plans being
canceled, everybody
and their cousin being on
bandwidth at the same time.
We're hoping that these tips
will help you get through that.
Now this is the
persona I had in mind
when I developed this deck.
Emily's pre-tenure your faculty
also teaches in industry.
She's comfortable
using modern tools.
She FaceTimes with her
partner all the time.
She struggles a bit with her
school's learning management
system, but that's blackboards
fault, that's not hers.
And now she's got to
move a class of 80 people
online in a week so that
they can finish semester
more or less on time.
And she's also got a
couple of workshops
that she signed contracts for.
She really doesn't want to
have to cancel out of those.
And above all of
this, she is afraid
that whatever happens in
the next few weeks is just
going to suck a lot of
time away from research,
and she's a year away
from applying for tenure.
And I put this concept map
together in order to figure out
what I was going to cover.
I wound up covering
more than this,
so I'm going to skip and go to
the first and most important
rule.
And if you take one thing
away from today's talk,
I want it to be this, don't
change what you don't have to.
There's an old saying, if
you're going on a long walk,
you wear old shoes.
You don't wear new shoes if
you've got a long way to go.
Please don't try to
change 19 different things
about your class because
you've heard that the right way
to teach online is
to use x or do y.
Right now, running late, running
without extra resources, what
we want to look for is the
smallest possible changes
we can make.
And that's what I'm
going to be focusing on.
The second rule,
and this one comes
from Elizabeth Wickes at
the University of Illinois,
please don't make assumptions.
Please ask your learners, your
students, your colleagues.
They aren't going to have the
same bandwidth that you have.
Their network might
not be as reliable.
Their computer at home might
be a six-year-old hand-me-down
because they're no
longer at the university.
In a corporate environment, it
might be the very first time
they've had to use
stuff over a VPN
because they're used to
going into the office.
And they may not have
the attention span
they used to because of all
of these pandemic-induced
distractions.
So rule number two, go and
ask and nobody will ever
be offended if you say, what
kind of device are you on,
how much time do you
realistically have.
The next recommendation
I've got is
please don't try to be or to
beat the kind of recorded video
you see in polished produce
courses on sites like EdX.
It takes a lot of time to
edit up even a simple video,
and it takes a lot of time
to learn the tools you
use for editing those videos.
You probably don't have
that time right now.
I'm not saying that recorded
video doesn't have its place,
we're going to
record this webinar
and make it available to people.
But right now, I think
in the short run,
your best bet is to try to use
things interactively and worry
about recording and editing
and publishing video later.
If you're going to
ignore my advice
and go ahead and start
doing it, there's
a really good paper from 2009
by Chen &amp; Rabb called A Pattern
Language for Screencasting.
They take a lot of, apparently,
straightforward ideas
and organize them
in a sensible way.
Their concept map is
up here on the screen.
There's just a whole
bunch of good tips
here about what makes for
a good screencast, what
makes for a good online video,
and how the parts fit together
so you know what not to do
or what not to venture into.
All of these slides,
by the way are going
to be available after the talk.
So if you haven't
copy down that URL,
don't worry you'll be
able to find it later.
Next thing I'm going to say is
the mistakes are the pedagogy.
Depending on whose
numbers you trust,
a professional programmer
spends 20% to 60%
of their time debugging.
A novice spends 80% to 95%
of their time debugging
because they're a novice.
The same is going to
be true in most areas.
So please don't worry
about making mistakes
in front of your
learners when you're
teaching online for the first
or the second or the third time.
Because every time
you make a mistake
and then say, oh, this is wrong.
Here's how I can tell, here's
how I figured out how to fix it
and here's how I can
tell it's been fixed.
They will have learned
something valuable.
And this comes back
to the larger point
that when you're teaching online
interactively, when you're
doing what I'm doing right
now, you learn the song
but then you improvise over it.
I've got a slide deck,
it has speaker's notes,
I'm really glad that
I prepped all of that
because it got me to
think through the things
I'm going to say.
But now what I'm actually
saying on any given day
is going to be
partly improvised.
It's going to depend
on the feedback
that I'm getting
from my audience.
It's going to depend on thoughts
that I have now that I'm
presenting, and that's OK.
The better you know your
material, the more comfortable
you will be improvising.
But don't think that you have
to stick to exactly what you
planned the night before.
And the corollary to this
is it's really, really hard
to teach to a roomful
of empty chairs.
All of us, all the time,
are picking up social cues.
We're constantly peripherally
aware of whether somebody
is nodding, or whether
they're checking their phone,
did they just yawn or are
they thinking because they're
about to ask a question.
You might not notice that
you're noticing but you notice.
And as soon as you start
teaching online, a lot of that
is taken away.
If you take all
of it away, you're
going to find it very,
very difficult to teach.
What I suggest you do
is get your students
into some sort of
webinar like this,
but then have a few of
them turn on their video
so that you can
see a few people.
If, for example, you're using
Zoom, which is my preferred
video conferencing tool, pick
a half a dozen names at random
and ask them to turn on video,
and then focus your attention
on those six.
Ask them your questions, pay
attention to their faces,
just as you would in a real
class, and in your next class
pick a different half dozen.
This teaching practice
predates video.
It was quite common.
It still is in some places.
If you've got a large
class to pick a few people
bring them down front and
focus your teaching on them
for this hour, but then focus
it on a different half dozen
for the next hour and so on.
They get individual
attention, you
get the kind of responsiveness
you need to make improvisation
and teaching lively.
And everybody else
now has permission
to turn off the video and
reduce the load on the system.
If you're going
to do this, please
give people a way to opt out.
For a whole bunch of
reasons, a lot of people
are uncomfortable
being on video online.
If you've ever had to deal
with harassment or a stalker,
you don't want images of
yourself appearing that might
go out of your control.
People have many other issues.
If they're working at
home for the first time,
for example, maybe
they don't want
others to be able to see
the mess in the background,
the kids playing, and so on.
So invite people, don't mandate
it, but try to get, as I said,
for five or six
people that you're
directing your teaching to.
That will keep you
engaged and you'll
do a better job with teaching.
The next one was recommended
by one of my colleagues.
And I'm embarrassed that I
didn't think of it because it
reveals my expert blindspot.
The first time you
move your class online,
give them a tour of the
tool that you're using.
They probably haven't seen
Zoom or whatever you've got.
They might not know where
to click the button to mute.
Seems obvious once
you know it's anything
but if you've just
been thrown into it.
So taking 10 minutes at the
start of your first online
lecture to show
people how you're
expecting them to use the tool.
Or taking an hour beforehand
to take a few screenshots
and then share those with the
class can save a lot of grief.
If you're going to
do this, make sure
that you're logged in as a
normal user, not as the teacher
or the conference organizer
when you're giving the tool,
because if you're logged
in as a super user
you will see a different set
of tools that they don't have
and that will confuse them.
The next one up is
to direct traffic.
You don't have to go
full North Korean, that's
where this pictures from.
But again, for a
lot of people, this
is their first time
being in some sort
of structured formal
setting online.
So always give them verbal cues.
Ask them to put their
questions in the chat.
Ask them to add their answers
to a homework question
to the shared Google Doc.
Call on them by name when
you want them to speak.
Or ask them to type
something like slash hand
or raise hand in the chat
when they want to speak.
Make sure that they're all
getting direction about what
they're supposed to do next.
After a while, you
can dial that down.
But I have found in my own
teaching that I don't--
I constantly do it
because I've constantly
got people who are new
or who are coming in
from somebody else's class
where they might have evolved
a different set of conventions.
Whatever it is, you, as the
tour guide, telling people now
we're moving on to the
Renaissance art section,
everybody step this way.
Again, it takes away a lot of
the uncertainty and right now,
people have got enough
uncertainty to deal with.
One other point on this,
mute early and mute often.
By default now when I'm
in Zoom, after somebody
finishes speaking, I don't
wait for them to mute.
I don't even mute
them, I instinctively
now hit the mute all button.
I put everybody back
in a muted state
even if they don't need to
be because that way I never
forget to.
You can do a very
good class audio-only
or audio with slides.
Video is helpful, but
it's not essential.
And I can prove
this by asking, what
would happen if we left you with
video of me talking right now
but turned off the sound?
You wouldn't learn anything.
You've got to make sure
that everybody can be heard.
You've got to make
sure that you're
not drowned out by feedback,
by background noise,
or crucially, by somebody
who constantly wants
to be the next one
to ask the question,
and constantly wants
to jump in first.
One thing that I do
to ensure that is I
actually keep a written list of
names beside me of the people
that I'm focusing
my teaching on,
that half dozen I
referred to earlier.
Every time I interact
with them, I just
put a tick beside their name
so that I can very quickly
see who I have been
talking to and who
I haven't been talking to.
That way, I can distribute my
attention more or less fairly
among those half dozen.
And if somebody is
constantly trying to jump in,
I can say no, it's
not your turn.
We're trying to take turns here.
If you are relying on people to
unmute themselves and just jump
in with their
questions, your class
is going to be dominated
by a couple of extroverts.
And everybody else
will very quickly
learn to not even bother
to try to ask questions
or to contribute ideas
because they can never
get in fast enough.
Mute early, mute often.
And then have people request
the microphone in order
to speak so that
you do the unmuting.
And as I said call
on people by name.
If I ask the room, are
there any questions?
It will be followed
with silence.
Sometimes that silence means
nobody has any questions.
Sometimes that silence
means people have questions,
but they don't want
to look foolish.
And sometimes that silence
means they're very busy typing,
and the question is going
to pop up in 15 seconds
by which point, I will
probably have moved on.
Instead when I want
somebody to contribute,
I call on them by name.
And if they want
to pass, if they
say I don't have
an answer, I don't
feel like this is the
right time, that's fine,
I'll move on to the next person.
Calling on people
by name also helps
you level out your classroom.
You are about to discover
that some of your learners
think much more
quickly than others.
That doesn't mean
they're smarter.
It doesn't mean they're
producing better work,
it just means that their
first response comes faster.
If you are calling
on people by name,
you can even that out
by throwing softballs
to people who might
need a little bit more
time, throwing harder
questions at people
who are a little quicker.
And that way the whole
class is progressing
at about the same rate.
This is all a lot to manage.
So this brings us to
the other big takeaway.
Don't teach alone.
If you can possibly avoid
it, don't be the only person
trying to run things.
Every great surgeon has
a great nurse beside her.
Every great teacher
has a co-teacher.
It could be a fellow
instructor, it
could be a TA, it could
be one of your learners
that you've
approached to say, you
seem to be OK with
this material,
can I ask you a favor?
Whoever it is, you
want somebody else
keeping track of whose
turn it is to speak next.
Somebody else making
sure that the slides
are presenting properly.
Somebody else who
is wrangling that
shared document that
we're going to talk
about in a couple of minutes.
You want a co-pilot who's
worrying about everything that
isn't the actual delivery
of the lesson in the moment
to free you up to focus on your
slides and what you're saying.
I've got that right now, and
it makes a world of difference.
It doesn't take
a lot of practice
to learn how to do that.
And it does also mean
that if next week you're
unable to make a scheduled
class, for whatever reason,
there's somebody else
who's at least partly
familiar with what
you're teaching
and with how you're
delivering it.
So do a dry run.
I have a list some place of
things that have gone wrong
while I've been teaching.
I've fallen off stage
twice and concussed myself.
Once I've had a
fistfight break out,
I've had a projector catch fire,
I've had a woman go into labor.
And I once actually fell asleep
in one of my own lectures.
Those are the easy ones.
The hard one is nobody told
me there was a firewall.
So all of a sudden, I can't
get any of the data sets.
Nobody told me that they've
updated Zoom and some
of the controls have moved
or behave differently.
Or I know all of that, but
I've never done it with Robert.
I've never done it with Karina.
And so we're used to using
the tool in different ways.
Getting 10 or 15
minutes, half an hour
before you're supposed
to start talking
can make a world of
difference to your delivery
and it can lower your blood
pressure considerably.
Another small note, keep
your notes the side you.
I've got a laptop on
my desk, and then I've
got a large screen
monitor above it.
I think that's a fairly
common setup these days.
What it meant was
that going back
a while whenever I was
teaching I was looking up
and have my head tilted back.
And my daughter
eventually told me
that as far as
she was concerned,
my webcam was in
those cam and that's
why I don't have a
picture for this slide.
If you've got your
notes beside you,
it's very natural to turn
your head to the side,
check what you're
going to say next
and come back to your lecture.
If you've got the
slides up here,
it's not something
you're used to doing
and the angle can be
rather unflattering.
I know it's a small thing,
but the small things add up.
A much larger thing, please add
speakers notes to your slides.
You are about to discover
that a lot of your learners
have trouble seeing or hearing.
They've got good compensating
strategies or accommodation
strategies in a live
classroom because they've
got a lifetime of
experience doing this.
They may not have
the same support
now that you're bailing
everything online.
If you put speakers
notes in your slides,
it makes the slides more
findable because search tools
know how to index them.
It makes the slides more usable
because people can understand
after the fact what you
meant by that picture,
but crucially, it makes
them more accessible.
And however hard you
think life is suddenly
being thrown online,
it's a lot harder
if you're partially
sighted or fully deaf.
Please don't make life
harder for people who already
have more to struggle with.
In fact, using accessibility
tools helps everyone.
I don't know if you can
see my cursor right now,
but I've used the
accessibility tools on the Mac
to make it as large as possible
so that it's easier for people
to see on video.
I do that whenever I'm teaching.
I use an enlarged cursor
because a small cursor
in a small window is
really, really hard to see.
I switched to high
contrast mode so
that people who might be
sizing down the screen,
or might be on older devices or
might just have crappy monitors
have a better chance of being
able to see what's going on.
All of these tools help
in key casting tools
that will show people on screen
all of the control keys, option
keys, and other things
that you're typing.
You should be using
those anyway when
you're teaching so that somebody
doesn't think you're typing 100
characters a
second, they realize
that you hit Tab and
got filing completion.
KeyCastr is one
that you can use.
[INAUDIBLE] another.
There's a lot of
accessibility tools out there.
Most of them are either
free or very cheap.
Most of them are
fairly easy to set up,
and they will all help
with your online teaching.
And when you're
done, keep using them
when you go back
in the classroom
because they'll make
life better for everyone.
This recommendation comes,
again, from Elizabeth Wickes.
Teach from your smallest screen.
If I try to take my
half meter wide monitor
and squeeze it down into
a little video window,
the video quality is
going to be pretty grainy
and the bandwidth demands
are going to be pretty heavy.
I'm not suggesting
that you teach
from a tiny handheld
device like this,
but please remember that
most of your learners
will be using smaller and
older gear than you've got.
You want to be at the
bottom of the pack
when you're the ones sending
out the video because that
has the greatest chance
of working everywhere.
And a lot of personal
footnote to this,
it's difficult to teach with an
IDE, when your screen sharing
because once you've
sized things down,
all of the controls in the
IDE for different tabs,
different menus, and so forth.
All of those things
that are really helpful,
they're taking up
a lot of space.
And you don't have a lot
of leftover real estate
for your own typing.
I have seen people put
RStudio IDE into a mode
where only one pane is
being shown at a time.
That's great from a real
estate point of view,
but now it looks very different
from what people are used to.
I don't have a
solution for this one,
ask your learners
what they prefer.
Circling back to a topic
from a few minutes ago,
your voice matters
more than your face.
You can switch off
video or you can
go to still images like this
one and give a decent class.
You cannot lose voice or voice
quality and still have a decent
class.
My setup is Samson
microphone and a $25 stand
for my local music store.
I got the stand so that the
microphone would be far enough
away from the keyboard that
it wouldn't be filled with all
the clicking as I type.
You can still hear the clicking,
but it's a soft background
noise rather than thunder.
Again, try out your rig
with your co-instructor
or with some randomly
selected student.
Or if you don't
have anybody else,
mail me and I will listen to it.
But getting the mic up
level with your head
about 30 centimeters
away from your mouth,
and away from your
keyboard, and that's as much
as you need to do now.
If later on you want to go
get spit guards and softballs
and do the full rig,
absolutely knock yourself out,
but you don't need to
do that first week.
What you do need to do is
turn off your notifications.
You don't want things popping
up on screen constantly telling
you that you've got mail, that
you've got something on Twitter
you should be looking at.
Turn slack off
completely whenever
I'm teaching, unless I'm
using it to communicate
with my students.
Because it's just
a distraction and
you can ask them to
turn theirs off as well.
I know that most won't.
And if you go into a in-person
classroom, stand at the back
and look over people's
shoulders, at any given time,
about a third of them are doing
something on their laptop.
Some of it is course
related some of it isn't.
Once you're in an
online environment,
there's going to be more of
that, but it's worth asking.
Again, if you've got a focus
group of about half a dozen
that you're directing
most of your teaching to,
they're more likely to switch
off distractions and actually
be engaged because
they're being called on
with higher frequency.
So you can get a high quality
experience for a small group,
and everybody else is going to
do what they would do anyway.
Now we come to that shared doc
that I've been talking about.
Excuse me a second, I
need a mouthful of tea.
Every time I teach
online, I create
something like a Google Doc
or a HackMD for those of you
who love markdown.
And I give edit permission
to the people I'm teaching.
Whenever I ask a question and
want a response from everybody,
I now have options.
I can either tell them
put it in the chat, which
I will do if I'm looking for a
one word or two word response.
Or if I'm asking
something a little larger
and they need to show
me a bit of code,
write a couple of sentences,
something like that,
they pasted in to the document.
I say pasted in
because a lot of people
don't want you to
see them typing.
I'm comfortable with that, but
I've been doing this for years.
What I see a lot
of newcomers do is
how to separate
text editor where
they're composing their answer
to question number three,
and then we'll copy
it and they'll just
paste it into the Google Doc.
That's cool.
As they become more
comfortable, maybe they'll
do their editing
directly in the doc
so that others can
see their mistakes
and see them being corrected.
That's cool too.
The important thing
is that it allows
you to see their
work in real time,
and that allows them to see one
another's work in real time.
That dramatically
improves engagement
and you get a lot of
peer to peer learning.
If you ask people
to, for example,
find the height of the
tallest person in Louisiana
in 1920 using a
dplyr pipeline, there
are three or four
plausible ways to arrange
the commands to do that.
Each person will
have one and then
they'll be able to glance at
a few others in the document
to go, oh, that's cool.
It's exactly like what
we do in a music class
where I say, OK, Janet
you play this piece.
OK, now Janine you
play this piece.
We're used to seeing and hearing
others work in live contexts.
We can do that online, and this
is probably the biggest change
in my teaching practice
over the last 10 years
is trusting learners
to share work
with each other in real time.
Couple of caveats for this.
Number one, if
you're going to do
it keep that list of half a
dozen names or the entire class
name depending on how many
are contributing to the doc.
Paste it into the doc before
they start typing, and do
that for each question so that
everybody knows where they're
supposed to start typing.
If you say just add
this to the doc,
you'll have two dozen
people putting their cursors
on top of each other
and colliding with one
another's work.
That's not helpful.
They'll very quickly opt out
because it's frustrating.
If on the other hand,
I've got a list of names
with a couple of blank lines
between them in the text file
and I pasted into the
doc, everybody immediately
knows where to type and
there's no collisions.
The second thing has
to do with scope.
Google doc will comfortably
support 14 or 15, maybe
16 concurrent typists.
It won't support 30.
You'll see a sudden dramatic
slowdown at some threshold.
And I've never done
the experiments
to measure where it
is but it's somewhere
between a dozen and 20.
Again, you solve this problem
by having a subset of people
contributing to
the shared document
and swapping that
out each time you
take a coffee break, each
time you restart your class.
Talked about this before,
keep track of who has
and hasn't spoken to make
sure that the people who
aren't extroverts
are getting air time.
Doesn't have to be
electronic, just a piece
of paper and a pencil beside
you putting tick marks in,
trying to make sure that you
distribute your attention
fairly so that everybody feels
like they're not just allowed
in the room, but they're
welcome in the room.
Ask-fill-call is a
pretty common tactic
from the days of
broadcast radio.
If I ask a question,
it's going to take people
a while to formulate an answer.
If I'm asking them for a long
answer, three lines of code,
for example, it's probably
going to take them 15 seconds
and even a gap of seven
seconds, which you just heard,
can be really uncomfortable.
So if I want somebody to
come in with a question,
I ask the question.
And then as they're composing
their answer, I fill the air.
I say something else.
I elaborate on a previous point.
They'll probably tune
me out while they
focus on their answer
so it can't be anything
too important,
but it's like it's
making small talk while
somebody is setting the table.
You want to ask a question, you
want to fill in a little bit
so that there's not
dead air, and then
you want to say, OK, Sarah,
now what have you got for us.
Again, you're doing this to make
up for the lack of social cues.
You don't have that peripheral
awareness of people's attention
so you're going to have
to be more directive.
Another way that you
can take advantage
of the online teaching is to
ask people for predictions.
This is particularly important
when you're teaching coding.
If I'm teaching a
programming class,
I'm probably sharing my
screen so that you can see
the code as I'm building it.
Every time I'm about
to do something,
I have an opportunity to
say, all right, everybody,
in the chat, what's going
to happen if I run it now.
I've just added this line,
how is it going to behave?
Pedagogically, this
is forcing people
to pull recent knowledge
back into consciousness
and use it and reinforce it.
That will help them
learn and remember.
From a motivational
point of view,
it increases their engagement.
They're constantly being asked
to think and to contribute.
And from your point of view,
it gives you a very quick
formative assessment.
For those who don't
know the term,
formative assessment
is what you do
during learning to
find out whether or not
people are learning.
It's your real
time feedback loop.
You cannot trust
people to go, got it,
I got it because a lot
of people will lie.
They'll say they have it
when they don't, or they'll
believe that they do
but they'll be wrong.
And they're even more
likely to mislead this way
when you're teaching online.
If, on the other hand,
I say, all right,
[INAUDIBLE] what's
this going to do next?
If they're right, you know
that their understanding.
If they're wrong, then
you know that you've
got something to explain
to clarify or to cover
a second time.
And you can do it
right then and there
before their misconception has
a chance to set in concrete.
This is a point where I would
normally pull my class to say,
how many of you
know breakout rooms.
For those of you who don't,
if you're using something
like Zoom, you can go
down and put everybody
into a small sub conversation.
You can assign them manually or
you can assign them at random.
You can vary the
size of the rooms,
and you can determine
how long they're
in that side conversation.
Here's a question, the
answer isn't obvious.
Everybody go and think
about it and then
argue with your three
partners and see
if you can come to a
consensus about what
this code does or doesn't do.
3, 2, 1, go.
You've got a couple of minutes,
and then I pull you back
and I pull a couple of people.
This emulates a practice
called peer instruction, which
is the most effective scalable
teaching practice we know.
The slide deck has
a link to a video
from a math class
in India in 2013
that illustrates the method.
Short version is I ask a
motivating question, something
whose answer requires more
than just factual recall.
You all then go and argue with
each other over the answer,
and then I pull you back and
give you the explanation.
Why the argument stage?
Because that's when
you have to think
through the inconsistencies
or gaps in your mental model,
and you've got other people
there who can fill them in.
And one of the great
discoveries is it doesn't really
matter if anybody in one of
these little discussion groups
is right at the start.
What matters is that you
disagree so that you can clear
up each other's misconceptions.
Pedagocially, it's a
well-justified method.
Practically, it also helps
with motivation because instead
of only teaching to half
a dozen for half an hour,
you can teach to that
half dozen and then
say, OK, now everybody is going
into a small discussion group
and then I'm bringing you
back, and now they have
to interact with their peers.
Again, you want people
to be able to opt out.
They may not be in
a situation where
they can have a conversation.
They might be in the living room
muted because the entire family
is here at the mall.
You've got to respect that.
Some people may be uncomfortable
arguing with strangers
at the outset of a class.
You respect that.
But for everyone else, it's
a very effective technique.
One of the things that we can't
do with any video tool I have
today is put people
into breakout rooms
in which they can all screen
share with each other.
I would really like to be
able to put people into pairs
and have them screen share
so that they can co-program.
The technology will
get there eventually,
but something like
that or a shared
whiteboard in the breakout
room would probably help a lot.
We just have to wait.
And since I mentioned
whiteboards,
Zoom provides polls so that
you can ask people questions
in real time and do a survey.
It also provides
a whiteboard don't
try to use it yet,
become comfortable
with the online
teaching, sort out
some of your other
problems, and then start
to try to take advantage
of all the science
fiction you've been handed.
You don't need it today.
Take advantage of it tomorrow.
The quote here
comes from my wife
who once explained to me that
the basic unit of teaching
is the bladder.
And I said, I've never
thought of it that way.
And she said, you've
never been pregnant.
You need to take a
break every hour.
Your back's going to
get sore, your voice
is going to get hoarse,
your learners are probably
in situations that are no
more comfortable than yours
and quite probably less.
And even when they're
comfortable, it's a long day
and it's a lot of coffee.
Make sure that you set yourself
a timer, I do it on my phone,
and have it go
off at 45 minutes.
I found
That when I was setting
timers for an hour
because I always
drift a little over,
we were only taking breaks
about every 75 rate minutes.
If I set the timer
for 45 minutes,
I'm pretty much guaranteed
a break every hour.
Whenever I set up for an hour I
always go over 5 or 10 minutes.
And to wrap up, before we
start taking questions,
I want you all to know
that nobody knows anything
right now.
We've been teaching online
in relatively small numbers,
in relatively constrained
technological environments
for a couple of
decades, maybe three.
And on the one hand, that sounds
like a lot, but on the other,
we are about to invent more
different ways to teach online
in the next 12 months than
we know in total today
because we're about to do
a whole lot of experiments.
You're going to suck
at this at first,
but that's a necessary first
step towards being good at it.
Don't beat yourself up.
And don't be afraid
to experiment.
Don't be afraid to
try things, and then
to say all right,
that didn't work.
I think everybody
understands that these
are unusual circumstances.
I think everybody,
I hope, is going
to give people a
little bit of slack,
give them a little bit
of allowance because
of the unusual circumstances.
So there's never been better
time to try new things.
Your audience will never
be more understanding.
And as I said at the
outset, we're here to help.
If there's anything we can do,
if there's any questions you
have, throw them at us.
Last thing before we
dive into the close,
if you've got time
to do any reading,
I highly recommend this book
by Brookfield and Preskill.
I've been talking about
things with people,
in large groups
since I was about 60.
Of the 50 different
techniques that catalog
in this book for having
a productive discussion,
I had only ever seen 15,
and I've only ever seen
five or six implemented online.
This is a catalog of
ways to get people
to talk to one another and share
information and make decisions.
A lot of them are directly
applicable to teaching.
And even if you don't
have direct customized
technical support, they're
all social conventions
that are fairly easy to adopt
in an online environment.
Just to pick one
example, suppose
I've got half a dozen
people that I'm focusing on.
All right, I want all of
you to put your answers
to this question
into the Google Doc.
OK, now that we've
got those, I want
you each to shift down one spot,
bottom person comes to the top,
and comment on the
answer from the person
that you're now looking at.
OK, now shift down one
more, so now you're
looking at an answer and a
previous set of comments.
People will learn so
much from each other,
and the peer to peer
knowledge transfer
will make up for so much of
what you're losing by not
having to physically present.
And that's just one idea
in a book full of 50.
Here are some links that I
found useful preparing this.
Jason Bell, in Australia, who I
believe is here with us today,
has a good video on what
it's like to teach software
carpentry workshops remotely.
He's in Queensland.
A lot of his learners
are scattered
so he's had to figure
out over the years
how you teach programming when
you are hundreds of kilometers
away from all of your
learners, and they're
hundreds of kilometers
away from each other.
Elizabeth Wickes, I
cited a couple of times,
has a really good set
of tips for teaching
tech subjects online.
Does a growing number of
comments in the RStudio
community teaching
discussion, you're
all welcome to join in their.
I'm a big fan of the piece
that Laura Czerniewicz wrote
in South Africa, what they
learned from going online
in Cape Town on short notice.
That link there
includes a sub link
to a document about
how to accommodate
wildly different technical
levels among your students.
They'll have differential
access to devices
to bandwidth, whole
bunch of things,
they've got a lot of experience
about how you accommodate that.
So please follow that one up.
And finally, just today
there was another blog post
from the Carpentries,
they're collecting their tips
for teaching online,
and again, there
are links to other resources.
So with all of that done, I
am hoping that some people
will have questions.
So Leon Justin is saying
that, calling people by name
is referred to as
harpooning and discourage.
Yes, like any
teaching technique,
it can be used badly.
You risk lower tier
and introvert students
leaving the teaching
platform because they
don't want to be called out.
I respect that normally,
you can detect that
or you can ask them in advance
to message you if they are
uncomfortable being called on.
Just have them tell
you, all right,
and respect whatever
it is they do.
Elisa Dillman is looking for
a list of accessibility tools.
Yes, we've got a
blog post hopefully
up sometime next week.
Does a cardioid mic help
reduce the keyboard noise?
It can.
This Samson isn't a cardioid.
I've just got it
by trial and error.
I've got to tilt it at an angle
where it seems to just pick up
my voice and not the keyboard.
For those who don't know
the term a cardioid mic,
picks up sound on one side or
the other, but not in between.
It's a directional
microphone intended primarily
for interviews where
you've got two people
on opposite sides of a mic.
One of the reason
I got the Samson
is that it's a cheap
enough microphone
that if I lose it while
traveling, I'm not heartbroken.
A good cardioid mic is
going to be more expensive.
Laura [INAUDIBLE] feel lost
reading all the feedback
from the students
in a shared doc.
Do you have any tips
to read the feedback?
This is part of what your
co-instructor can do for you.
Normally when I'm teaching,
I will call a one or two,
but I've got somebody
else there just
as I've had Robert and Curtis
going through your questions
and flagging them.
So that by the time I
get there, somebody else
has already done the
first pass of filtering.
Ryan Davis, for smaller
class doing quick intros
at the start.
Absolutely, if
you've got the time,
if you're comfortable doing it.
And then Kelsey
[INAUDIBLE] do you
have a tactic for keeping
track of participant responses?
When they may have strange
and recognizable names,
yes, I sometimes
now have learners
whose name field is an emoji.
In those cases, I
will ask people,
can you please change it for
the duration of the session,
or just let me know
how to address you.
I find that asking people how
do you want to be addressed also
helps with internationalization
of names and pronouns.
I'm quite often not sure
which of the several parts
of someone's name
the most useful--
most used to being called
by particularly when
I get into East Asian
and South Asian cultures
that I'm not familiar with.
And it's always a good idea
to ask people what pronoun
they would like you to use.
Students don't turn on
the video because they
don't feel comfortable.
This one's coming
from Gaby Sandoval.
In many cases,
they don't turn it
on because they're
busy with other things.
They don't want you to
see that they are also
doing their calculus
homework while they're
supposed to be in your class.
I ask them I try to create an
environment in which they're
comfortable being seen focusing
on a small number at a time
does seem to help with this.
I think it's partly
a matter of trust.
I'm afraid I don't have
anything more specific than that
that I can recommend.
I think people are
going to become
more comfortable
in a hurry as we
all start doing a lot
more online in a hurry.
Lyn Williams, how do you work
with Google Docs and HackMD
when it's new to your class?
And they've said it's
use is overwhelming.
Really good question.
I don't use it on day one.
I will sometimes for
instructor training
because we've only got
a one, but in a lot
of other circumstances,
I'm going
to introduce these
practices to people
one at a time over the
course of several lessons.
First day, just get them used
to using Zoom and taking turns
speaking because that's
the most important thing.
Second class with them,
get them used to the idea
that when I ask a
question, they can all
give short responses in chat.
It's not archived, it'll fly.
By I probably don't
even read all of them
but I'm getting used
to them getting them
used to contributing.
Things like a
focus group, things
like turning on their
own video, things
like using the Google Doc,
lesson two, lesson three.
Coming down a bit,
how do you make
sure each student
is paying attention?
You can't.
This is from Mathias.
We can't do it in person either.
I remember very clearly being in
an electrical engineering class
watching a colleague teach.
And since I was
standing at the back
and looking down
these rows of seats,
I could see that almost
a third of the students
were playing poker online
during the lecture.
We're not going to
do better than that
when we shift them all online.
What we can do is the best we
can with the tools we have.
Karina Marks, whereby.com Skype
for business, Microsoft Teams.
I like whereby.com a lot.
For those of you
who haven't seen it,
it uses modern web
standards like webRTC.
It's a beautiful little tool.
I think Skype for Business is
a really good advertisement
for Zoom.
I was on a Skype
call Tuesday night
for the first time in ages
with my guitar teacher
and we're going to
try Zoom next time.
I haven't used Microsoft Teams.
I'd be interested in other
people's experience of using it
as a teaching platform.
Is there a way to help teachers
how to Zoom if we never have?
From Michelle Connor.
OK, if you mail me, I'm
greg.wilson@rstudio.com, we'll
set up a session, we'll
show you what we know.
Other recommended
platforms for videocalls
calls from [INAUDIBLE] basis.
I'm in Toronto, Canada,
I know what works here.
I would be very
grateful from comments
from other people about what
has worked where they are.
I don't know what a
good videoconferencing
solution is in Argentina or
Malaysia or South Africa.
I don't want to give you
misleading information,
but please throw it into the
RStudio community channel,
or throw it to me
and I'll share it.
Why is dead air so bad?
A couple of moments of quiet
time after hearing a question
is fine, but a couple
of moments really
does mean a couple of moments.
People will become
very uncomfortable
with a silence like the
one I just did, right?
If they've got video and can
see that you're still there
that reduces it a bit.
But it is still uncomfortable
to have a long pause.
And Jeremiah is asking,
these are great,
but many ideas relate to
live or synchronous teaching.
With my students
scattered, this won't work.
Any advice on
making asynchronous
teaching compelling?
That one's actually
easier to do online
because you're already
doing a lot of it.
You're probably already
publishing your slides.
You're probably
already using some sort
of homework submission system.
You probably, hopefully, already
have some sort of discussion
forum or board or mailing
list set up for your class.
That stuff won't change.
If your administration
is pushing
you to record and publish
videos on short notice,
please push back.
It's a lot of work.
If you're worried
about burning it,
particularly now that you're
juggling everything else,
that's going to be the
one that breaks you.
If you're already
doing async teaching
with text and images
and static documents,
that's the way you want to run.
Leon Jessen, I could
see who is online
and during the four-hour
class I lost some
of the lower-tier students.
So Leon, I would ask
did they drop out
because it was a
four-hour class?
Four hours is a long
time in one chunk.
I mean, human attention is 45
to 90 minutes without a reset.
I think if you're putting
people into a four-hour class,
you're going to lose people
for a whole bunch of reasons.
I couldn't do it these
days because of my back.
I simply can't sit-in a
chair for four hours at a go.
The second question is would
be, when you say lower-tier,
you mean people who
are less advanced,
people who have
less technical skill
or have a less solid
grasp of the material.
In which case, they
were checking out
in your in-person class as well.
It just wasn't as obvious,
they were physically present
but mentally, they had checked
out and now you're seeing it.
And one of the things that we
get from people logging out
of Zoom logging
on video calls is
that we can actually see
who's checking out in a way
that we couldn't before.
It's not creating the problem
necessarily, it's revealing it.
And that may sound like
I'm making an excuse
or trying to explain it
away, the honest truth
is I don't know and I don't
know of any research on this.
Amato Deko, do you
have any tips to notice
quickly when you're losing
someone during a training?
Pair them up, put them in
groups as quickly as possible
so that their peers
can support them.
Breakout rooms, pair
wise discussions,
having them review each other's
work in a shared document,
things like that.
You can't give individual
attention to a dozen people
at once, never
mind a class of 50.
They can give attention
to each other.
The one thing that
you have to monitor
is that they're
not being trolls.
Provided attendance is
named, not anonymous.
You've got some sort
of control over that.
But if you have 50
people anonymously
in a classroom giving
each other feedback,
somebody is going to
be rude to somebody
and then you've
lost the learning.
So I strongly prefer that
people identify themselves.
And I think since
most of us are working
in formal educational
contexts, either university
classroom or a paid
training event,
it's OK to ask for real names.
Jeffrey Thompson, we're doing
asynchronous instruction,
recording short videos
of students watched them
and then holding
virtual office hours.
Great.
This is the equivalent
of a flipped classroom.
Flipped classroom is one where
the students learn the material
out of class and do the homework
in class so that when they're
actually trying to
apply the knowledge,
you're right there with them
when they need you most.
Have them work through problems
in that shared session.
Ask one of them to
share their screen
and actually saw the
small programming problem.
Or if they've got a
tablet in a fingertip
to work out an equation
there in front of people.
You would bring
somebody up and have
them to work on a whiteboard
in an in-person class.
You would have
somebody play a passage
on a saxophone in
the band class.
You can do that to
improve engagement,
and to take full advantage
of the interactivity
of those office hours.
Skipping down again.
Tips for engaging when there
are many, many students?
All right, something I
should have emphasized more
during the presentation.
You are not going to be able
to do better in the next three
months shifting
online than you're
doing right now in person.
One person lecturing
to a class of 1,000
is a poor learning experience.
It doesn't matter if
it's online or not.
Peer instruction goes a long
way towards addressing them.
Getting them talking to
each other in small groups
periodically to clear up
each other's misconceptions
is a proven scalable
approach to this.
But if you're trying to take
broadcast instruction where
you're the one delivering
information to all of them
in an in-person class, a
lot of them aren't engaged
and a lot of them are lost.
You just don't realize it.
So we're not going to be
able to do better right away.
My goal for the next 90 days
is just not to do worse.
Coming down to a
couple of others
because we're
almost out of time.
Excuse me.
Some more questions
about async teaching.
Can you talk about
adding captions
to live-streamed
content on Zoom?
Absolutely.
I had speaker's notes
to the slide deck
rather it than captioning
the live-streamed content
because I find that's
easier for people to search.
I don't have a lot of
experience with adding captions
to Livestream content.
If you can throw that
question to me by email,
I'll go and find
somebody who's done
this more than I have and we
will come back and give you
an answer.
Lisa Johnson, any
advice for sticky notes
substitutions for participants
to give feedback on the pace?
For those of you who don't
know a trick pioneered
in the Carpentries workshops
is to give everybody
a green sticky and a red sticky.
Green sticky means
things are going OK.
Red sticky means I've got
a problem, I need help.
In Zoom, people can set an icon
thumbs up, thumbs down, how am
I feeling about this right now.
It's kind of hard for
you as the teacher
to monitor those so that's
something your co-pilot can do.
I wish there were better
controls or something
a little more
adaptive to indicate,
but you can use thumbs
up, thumbs down in Zoom.
I don't know if this is
similar capability in GoToMe--
GoToWebinar rather.
Coming down a little further.
Software for online teaching.
Take a video conferencing
tool, pick a wiki tool
or use Google Docs.
Picks something
for real time chat,
it can be Slack
or anything else.
I don't recommend any of
the custom-integrated tools.
Most learning management
systems are actually
grading management systems.
They don't really
help with the learning
and the interactive experience.
Lisa Johnson, you
have audio tips--
to tips for audio issues
where more than one student
has something to say
at the same time.
Mute everybody and then
you invite somebody
into the conversation.
Parliamentary rules, nobody
speaks unless the speaker
calls on them.
When you're doing that,
your job as the teacher
becomes that as more
of a traffic director.
You're deciding who
speaks next and why.
It doesn't take very long
for people to get used to it.
And if you're proactive
about meeting everybody,
they'll pretty quickly
learn that they're not
going to be allowed
to break that rule.
How do you deal with trolls?
Sadir Shukla.
Really important question,
you deal with them
the same way that you would
in an in-person class.
You start by reminding everybody
that there is a code of conduct
and certain rules are
expected to be followed.
Everybody gets one warning.
They may not understand
that they've transgressed.
After that, yes,
absolutely, shut them down.
Mute them and leave the muted.
Disable their
access to the talk.
I recommend that you don't
kick them out of the room
so that they're unable to see
your presentation because then
they might go and
complain to somebody.
But take away their ability to
impede other people's learning
experience.
As soon as somebody is a
troll, your responsibility
is no longer to them, it's to
all of your other learners.